c'est gentil de m'amener le café
beaucoup de cailloux des trous des
cailloux du mou il y avait
[Musique]
tout 13 janvier Gao au Mali après la
boucle infernale Gao moptit Gao les
rescapés du 4e Paris Dakar pensent leur
blessures l'année dernière équipage m
Girou avait remporté l'é preuve en
voiture cette année leur rangech ne
semble pas leur donner toute
satisfaction je réveille
dur je
t'entend
9h5 gen
ça mieux j'étais détruit hier soir ou je
peux même plus
parler ça a été dur la boucle grave
c'est
chaudhémisme c'était pire que ça
l'enfer c'était Paris Roub en voiture
c'est gentil de m'amener le café
beaucoup de cailloux des trous des
cailloux du mou il y avait tout vous
êtes à presque 2 heur des premiers des
frères Marau c'est irrémédiable ou vous
pensez pouvoir remonter oh non pas du
tout l'année dernière on était 2e à 3h
donc c'est
l'écart c'est pas un problème je pense
euh ce qui m'inquiète un peu c'est que
dans les quatre premiers qui enfin les
quatre premier il y a des voitures qui
n'ont qui n'ont pas encore souffert et
ça ça me ça m'étonne un petit
peu faire un problème avec votre Cousse
de
toilette ça va tellement vite qu'elle a
explosé les tous les tubes les tub de
dentifrice de crème à rangée tout
explosé il y en a pas j' effectivement
très vite avec Jack X mais vous avez eu
un problème de pénalisation qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé et bien on sait on sait
qu'effectivement on a commis une petite
erreur de
parcours qui n'avait rien à voir avec de
la tricherie je m' me presse de le dire
puisque effectivement il y avait un
endroit sur la carte sur le roadbook
c'était pas très clair sauf ceux qui
pour ceux qui connaissaient les tapes et
qui connaissaient l'Afrique du fait que
nous nous sommes un petit peu égarés à
savoir qu'on a fait euh
à peu près 70 km de plus et il y a une
aberration dans le règlement c'est que
le fait de s'être trompé d'avoir fait 70
km de plus donc de ne pas avoir triché
ça me para évident on est pénalisé de 5
heette pénalisation x brassur aurait
facilement gagné la course mais avec des
paris dak ne serait pas ce qu'il est
toute la journée les concurrents
mécanique en Afrique avec des idées et
de la soudure tout
est casser un moteur et crever plusieurs
fois pour lui rien ne va
plus pour moi hier entre M petit et Gao
bon ben j'ai crevé trois fois et là j'ai
repris encore 2 heur alors ça fait ça
fait beaucoup le moral est touché ouais
le moral est touché parce que j'aV
encore une petite chance avanttiier
peut-être pas de victoire mais d'être
dans les trois premiers au moins mais là
est très touché là c'est je sens bien
que c'est c'est terminé pour moi je vais
je vais arriver à Dakar je vais on va
essayer de faire gag une Honda et puis
puis
[Musique]
voilà cette fameuse boucle cassante
épuisante affreusement longue offrira
aux concurrents des paysages grandioses
mais ont-ils pu les apprécier
[Musique]
chez les motos les grands absents du
rendez-vous de Gao seront les BMW Oriol
a cassé deux boîtes et un pont le chef
d'écurie exige l'abandon de fenouill et
de l'oiseau dommage régulière endurante
et obstinée mar première des dames à Gao
est 13e au
général à quoi vous pensez quand vous
êtes sur votre moto sur la piste quel
est votre anti vous avez une idée fixe
quelque chose oui la crevaison pour ça
je gonfle un maximum et puis bon j'ai de
quoi réparer tout ce qui c'est à peu
près la seule chose que j'ai sur moi
parce que toute façon je sais pas faire
grandchose même je sais rien faire en
mécanique qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans cette
petite trousse alors moi alors j'ai de
l'huile parce que je consomme pas mal
d'huile c'est vital et puis bon ben j'ai
bon mes fusé de détresse j'en ai moins
que dans la partie par maintenant per
plus beaucoup de villag une bombe
anticevaison une pompe des rustines du
fil de fer mes outils et derrière des
chambres
àirp pour Mar le côté féminin pas de
rouge à lèvres pas de crème rien du tout
j' rien du tout avec moi j'ai pas de
place orol Vassar Rigoni se sont
succéder au commandement de la course à
drec hérite de la première place mais le
moral n'y est pas
au début c'était assz assez grisant et
tout maintenant ça devient vraiment la
galère toute façon on m'avait dit
beaucoup de truc sur Paris Dakar et tout
mais là c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
plus dur que je
pensais l'exploit impossible a mené un
side de Paris à Dakar et P sont bien
partis pour pouvoir le réaliser sans
pièces sans aide quelques pilotes privé
survivent je suis perdu une
fois
pénalité et pour ça aujourd'hui je dois
être horors classement mais je continue
je fais 14 he en moyenne sur la moto sur
14h on peut pas être concentré pendant
14h alors on se relâche un peu une pièce
facile on regarde le paysage on part en
l'air parce qu' 17 cm de débadement de
suspension on est tout de suite parti la
moto quoi surtout j'ai tout dans le sac
à dos alors c'est un coup dans le dos un
coup dans les épaules à chaque foiso
vous transporteros vos pièces j'ai tout
dans le sac à dos j'ai rien autrement
mais mes pièges j'en ai plus j'ai tout
perdu il me reste une chambre à air une
clamolette et un démon
menu le beau camion d'assistance
embourbé les frères Marau sont une fois
de plus livrés à eux-mêmes mais avec du
fil de fer un marteau et un poste de
soudure Bernard et Claude savent faire
des miracles eux aussi ont souffert plus
difficile que l'année dernière beaucoup
plus cassant c'estàdire la différence se
fait pas entre 140 km/h et 120 kmh et se
fait plus dans les passages de caillou
entre 5 km/h et 15 km/h
quand on a cassé on sauve ce qui peut
encore être sauvé perdu depuis plusieurs
jours Serge Bacou rejoint enfin Gao
j'avais à peu près 1 L et demi d'eau
j'avais deux rendelles de pâte de fruits
tout ça pour 3 jours et 3 nuits ça
faisait très peu vous auriez pu tenir
combien de temps à votre
avis je crois que c'est c'est moral
tenir je m'étais donné encore jusqu'à la
fin de la semaine mais on TI le temps
qu'on veut aussi bizarre que ça paraisse
bien que physiquement j'étais déjà
diminué j'avais j'avais perdu pas mal de
force je je sentais la soif venir
c'est-à-dire la langue qui doublait de
volume le la salive qui ne remonte plus
au fond de la gorge je pouvais encore
tenir un certain nombre de jours
maintenant pour faire quoi pour rester à
l'ombre à l'OM de ma moto de la journée
essayer de me réchauffer la nuit c'est
ça le
problème l'équipage touchur Vernet
Garnier n'est toujours pas localisé un
Breg Atlantique et un Nord Atlas venu de
Dakar ratissent le désert voiture 179
voiture 179 du Breg Atlantique pour
contact radio
parler finalement ce seront des
gendarmes algériens qui les retrouveront
quelques heures plus tard à tessalite la
première
interview passer dans le désert 6 jour
et Sin nuit n'est certainement pas la
chose la plus agréable qui puisse
arriver mais si vous avez assez d'eau et
de nourriture si vous n'êtes pas seul et
si vous respectez une certaine
discipline c'est
supportable mais si vous quittez la
voiture si vous buvez trop d'eau alors
là c'est de la
folie les premiers jours non et puis
après bon je franchement je pensais que
c'était fini réellement ah réellement là
je crois que même nous avons été tous
les tris dans le même à votre avis on
peut tenir combien de temps dans le
désert à cette époque on a eu un gros
problème parce que notre JIC a explosé
pendant la spéciale ce qui fait qu'on
s'est retrouvé avec les TR l d'eau que
nous ont passé les Suisses qui étaient
avec nous et on pouvait même plus boire
c'estàd que le matin on a le droit à un
demi ver d'eau qu'on gardait sous la
langue rejit dans le ver et tout pour
que ça fasse toute la journée et là je
pense qu'on tenit encore de jours comme
ça mais pas beaucoup
plus drobec est tombé et c'est luxer
l'épaule Vass Rigon Albaret ont passé un
contrôle à l'envers jean-pa mingeloro le
bal mais à quelques kilomètres du départ
ce sera la chute et l'abandon il
représentait le dernier espoir de
Yamaha Merel 3è l'année dernière tente
l'impossible mais ses problèmes
mécaniques lui ont fait perdre trop de
temps Cyr neveu que l'on attendait plus
va pour la trè fois remporter ce
marathon son courage son flire sa sûreté
de pilotage ont fait la différence
Philippe Vassard assure son assistance
immédiate pas de grand bouleversement
dans le classement auto les Marau
à Jean-Claude briavan privé de son
assistance depuis le début de la course
se maintient à la seconde place MEDGE
cassera son moteur à 150 km de
Dakar voici le X Express multipliant les
Scrat
as leôle de passage man term 5 derrière
[Musique]
l'AR côté camion victoire du Mercedes de
Gran de saieu
MalF R et P ont gagné leur Paris amen un
dak Nicole MRO remporte la coupe des
dames après la casse mécanique de
Mar la première année on y va pour voir
pour l'aventure pour l'Afrique et puis
quand on a quand le r se termine on dit
que jamais plus jamais on y remettra les
pieds et puis 6 mois après il y a une
petite envie qui vous prend et puis
cette envie croit croit et puis et puis
on repart pourquoi je sais pas pour
l'exploit gratuit
peut-être
[Musique]